[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous qu'ils étaient avec nous et on la
retrouvera jeudi prochain alors on
commence les génies du pas vous le savez
on fait un petit tour des télés réalités
et par les marseillais forcément et la
star de la semaine c'est bien sûr
grecque
greg on le quitte alors que c'est le
moment de faire un petit point sur la
situation amoureuse de grecs
cette personne que j'aime beaucoup et
sur deux dossiers en simultané il est
sûr maeva et mélanie alors lundi il a
fait chaud mais ira mardi il à pécho
mélanie et hier il a essayé de pécho
mélanie et maeva away ah oui retour en
images sur ses performances et vous
allez voir ce qui se passe actuellement
c'est parti mes sentiments tels que ben
oui c'est pas ils diminuent en fait je
ne peux pas vous autorise à passer toute
ma vie j'ai tant la pause les dans la
rouge jours c'est incompréhensible en
fait même moi je comprends pas même moi
même moi je comprends pas vraiment ça y
tourner la page maintenant que j'aille
de l'avant
c'est au moins la dixième fois qu'ils me
le dit c'est juste que j'ai un coeur et
que je réfléchis avec mon coeur tout
simplement au liban à mon avis ces morts
sur les dodos si elle est grillée de
partout le gard et bien messieurs 12 10
on a tous des leçons à prendre
voilà de ce jeune homme deux grecs
puisque le mec il arriva trop tourner la
tête d'une meuf en 7 secondes chrono
c'est le patron
regardez c'est parti j'étais jamais
critiqué j'ai jamais tu as quand même
pour ça quand même et a quand même été
tirana il va je m'en bats les de cette
fille devant moi je m'en bats les sept
filles parce que la lorraine je pourrais
me pardonner ouais
c'est moi
rometty attaché à moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas s'embrasser que je pense à vibe
mise à l'eau un ballon mais c'est vrai
ouais laisse-moi redescendre de tout ce
que tu as dit y est avancé je t'explique
moi j'ai besoin d'une femme je tombe des
nues une gamine en fait
et toi tu y vas
[Applaudissements]
je te préviens comprendre
c'est bon je suis pas mélanie elle vient
bien de prévenir y arrête de faire de la
merde à battre a dit est ce que greg a
fait de la merde grec s'est arrêté bah
non et non alors résultat toutes les
copines de mme elhady ou décidé de lui
faire payer son comportement alors que
le pauvre greg il n'y est pour rien
comme il le dit toujours c'est pas de sa
faute c'est son coeur il est sinon c'est
pas greg il a tout le temps être sur le
dos de mélanie alors qu'il a fait
souffrir depuis plusieurs jours non pas
que je vais déjà que j'étais tellement
c'est le talent qui fait la queue de la
charité un jouet ce qui peut être de
pleurs d'un à dire qu'on est plus
intéressant est ce que c'est normal
est ce que c'est normal parce que c'est
bien beau moi de me faire des reproches
de me faire passer pour le méchant je
suis pas encore à 100% avec le crabe
avec le chant avec la paix j'ai fait moi
j'ai le coeur j'aime bien de coeur
[Musique]
aulas dans la dore braga il embrasse pas
grave alors les chéris ballast et
d'autres petits résumés des bars ayez et
si ce petit bonus c'est pour vous vous
êtes pudique pour le dire ce soir
benjamin mais vous attendez je crois un
heureux événement et votre femme a déjà
mis en ligne la vidéo dans laquelle elle
annonce tu sais que se donne à fond
je rappelle la règle cicero c'est une
fille si ces bleus c'est un garçon savez
pas ce que c'est mais où on envoie des
fumigènes à bio pas donc si je les
bichonne des balles exactement donc si
ce héros c'est une fille c'est beau
c'est un garçon eh bien regardez
apparemment benjamin ah oui voila voila
c'est une surprise
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureux en fait ce n'est
pas rien comme ça mais je trésor c'est
une amie à la haye la dentelle à elle
adore ça